hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain an intriguing and mind-blowing
science fiction movie from black mirror
seasons 3 called play test
black mirror is an anthology series
meaning that you do not need to watch
the previous episode to understand this
movie
the movie begins with a man named cooper
who packs his bag in his room preparing
to go abroad for a short vacation
he silently leaves his house and several
times ignores his mother's phone calls
he travels the world starting from india
australia dubai and many more making as
many memories as he can
in london he feels jealous seeing a
couple kiss in front of him thus he
installs a dating app and starts looking
for girls until he finds a young woman
named sonia
that night he meets her who turns out to
be a technology journalist in a bar
where he reveals his real purpose of
traveling around the world is to get
away from the family home
they go to sonia's place and they have
fun together
cooper's mom suddenly calls him again
but he keeps ignoring the calls for
unknown reasons
cooper later explains that his father
died from alzheimer's disease last year
and he is not even close with his mom
because of that he feels it's the best
way to leave the house at some point
cooper realizes that he has to go back
to america and intends to buy a ticket
unfortunately he is unable to access his
bank account he calls the customer
service but the man informs him that he
finds several unidentified transactions
and his bank account has been drained he
becomes desperate and has nowhere to go
therefore he goes back to sonya's place
sonia welcomes him warmly not long after
cooper opens his job search app and
coincidentally finds a paid offer to
play test a brand new game for cider
jammu which is a big horror game company
owned by shusaido
sonya then takes cooper to the company's
hq
in the building cooper is fascinated
with one of saito jammu's game posters
and shortly after he is approached by
katie she guides cooper to the
experiment room
however before they enter the room katie
orders him to hand over his phone and
then turns off the phone
before they begin the experiment cooper
signs an nda but he finds that the
signature page is missing as katie
leaves the room he immediately turns on
his phone and takes a picture of black
case then sends it to sonia
after cooper agrees to the terms katie
installs the device and implants a tiny
device called mushroom to his neck
afterwards she commences the experiment
but suddenly his phone rings as he
forgot to turn it off again
the installation process went well
causing cooper to be able to see things
the gopher projection gradually becomes
more detailed and cooper even attempts
to play whack-a-mole with it katie
concludes that cooper is ready for the
real experiments and escorts him to shoe
saito's room
cyto claims that the game will be the
most personal survival horror game in
history because its artificial
intelligence will adapt and
automatically adjust the game's flow
based on the player's greatest fears
the company's owner then uploads some
data to cooper through the mushroom
after that cooper is taken to harleq
house where the real experiment will
take place
there katie tells cooper that his main
mission is to stay as long as he can
while his activities will be monitored
in the control room
she gives him an earpiece to maintain
communication with katie
she informs him that the emerging things
won't harm him as they are just a
projection
after katie leaves him alone cooper
explores the house where he eventually
finds a bottle of wine
he is amazed with the craftsmanship of
the house's stuff while keeps talking to
katie through the earpiece while he is
reading a book suddenly a spider emerges
and scares him he eliminates the spider
only to find out that it is just another
projection
a few moments later the light suddenly
flashes and he realizes that a figure
somehow appears in the painting of the
house
cooper hears loud footsteps from
upstairs so he goes to the stairs when
josh peters his childhood bully out of
nowhere appears and startles him as he
anticipated the bully is just a
projection and doesn't move at all
katie explains to him that the system
could be mining some of his personal
memories and cooper was scared of him
while he was at high school
cooper then walks through him and gets a
glass of wine again
katie concludes that he is afraid
because he suddenly becomes talkative to
compensate for the fear
in the kitchen a wild huge spider with
peter's face suddenly appears
unfortunately katie who is observing
from the surveillance camera can't see
anything as the event is just happening
in cooper's mind
to make things worse the earpiece
suddenly ceases to work
soon after cooper hears someone banging
on the house's door
he bravely opens the door and sonia
randomly shows up
she states that cooper might be in
danger and urges him to leave
immediately
however cooper thinks that his encounter
with sonia is just part of the
experiment
sonia tries to convince him that the
experiment is dangerous
she reveals to him that five people and
all of them were tourists have
disappeared in the past year because
they applied themselves to the play test
job
cooper refuses to leave and still does
not believe every single word coming
from her mouth
sonja becomes upset and grabs a knife
threatening to hurt cooper
she manages to stab him and they fight
for a moment
getting cornered cooper then impales her
on a knife lodge through his shoulder
and the knife and sonia suddenly
disappear
the earpiece starts working again and
cooper goes crazy because sonia and the
fight feel so real for him
katie makes it clear that physical
sensation shouldn't be possible but
cooper refuses to continue the
experiment anymore
katie leads him to an upstairs room
where katie and cyto appear to terminate
the experiment however there's a
malfunction that prevents the
experiments from stopping
cyto apologizes to him and asks the men
to bring cooper to the others
cooper screams in fear and eventually
awakens in saito's office
katie immediately removes the mushroom
while revealing that the experiment only
lasted for one second
afterwards
cooper flies back to america and returns
to his house only to find that his
mother can't even recognize him anymore
and is still trying to call her son
the scene then moves back to the very
first experiment room where cooper
repeatedly yells for his mom as the
mushroom kills him because the phone
unexpectedly rings
saito comes to the room and they
conclude that the phone's signal
interfered with the upload process
causing all of cooper's synapses in his
brain to light up at the same time and
killing him in less than a second
they then put cooper's dead body into a
body bag and now his mom will never know
his son's whereabouts
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching